[Musique]
on va être débuté pour se plonger dans
l'esprit de noël
direction le château de breteuil oui le
château qui connu pour ses contes de
perrault animé il ne fait pas l'impasse
sur noël la demeure séparer de ses
guirlandes et nous l'avons visitée dès
le jardin on comprend que c'est le noël
au château de breteuil
pour découvrir l'ensemble des
décorations jean-emmanuel chars aux
administrateurs de la demeure nous la
fait visiter le circuit sera décoré dans
cette ambiance festive jusqu'à la fin
des vacances de noël
c'est un travail de plus de 15 jours
réalisée par lydie paillis de la
jardinière et pour la da silva
l'intendant dans la salle à manger du
personnel du château
l'ambiance qui reconstituait s'est
déroulé en mai 1905 lorsque le roi
edouard vii d'angleterre est venu
déjeuner au château
son chauffeur est reçu à table par le
personnel
qu'ils leur soient dignement on a en
plus évidemment la fée des décors de
noël avec ce magnifique sapin est un
thème ou juste cette année dans sa halle
du château sont proposés à la visite et
reconstitue une histoire et donc c'est
l'ambiance début de siècle du 20e siècle
et reconstituer la maîtresse de maison
très jolie robe est descendu superviser
les derniers préparatifs pour le
déjeuner donné ses consignes aux chefs
cuisiniers quand on monte les étages on
arrive dans les pièces des propriétaires
avec une table de noël est furieuse
invité sur rouge qui côtoie barbe bleue
et le prince charmant cendrillon ou le
marquis de carabas pièces maîtresses
cette année une robe de réveillon dans
le salon de musique créée à partir de
branches de sapin
on est très content de cette nouveauté
on espère comme ça crée une nouvelle
robe chaque année à partir de 2018
chaque personnage du château a droit à
son décor spécial les chats bottés qui
sont la mascotte du château jeûneront
autre que l'on retrouve un peu partout
lentilles recul de la visite ici dans la
bibliothèque vous avez le chat libraires
et son élève et qui sont très bien
entouré d'un magnifique village de noël
si sapins sont répartis tout au long de
la visite le plus somptueux étant
réservé à la grande galerie thompson
dans la grande galerie du château où il
ya les plus grands portraits de famille
et puis certains portraits royaux effet
dans cette pièce que nous avons mis le
plus grand sapin il fait 4 mètres
cinquante de hauteur
et puis de l'autre côté de la cheminée
le père noël est un fauteuil attendent
les visiteurs qui veulent se faire
prendre en photo
la visite du château se fait tous les
après midi et pour les vacances
scolaires ont commandé une de france
jean-emmanuel charroux administrateur du
château de breteuil est en plateau avec
une bienvenue sur ce plateau pour soir
bonsoir
on va donc parler un petit peu plus de
ce qui est proposé le château de
breteuil malaise alors dans le reportage
on voit la visite du château mais il ya
aussi les scènes de compte est justement
une nouvelle arrive pendant les vacances
tout à fait c'est barbe bleue
barbe-bleue existait déjà mais nous
l'avons entièrement rénové c'est un peu
désuète et on l'a mise au goût du jour
tout comme on avait déjà précédemment
fait pour cendrillon ou peau d'âne
cette année c'est barbe-bleue qui va
être entièrement en son et lumière et
qui vatry donc inauguré au rang des
vacances de noël un abus sud ça a été
fait par christophe laure est tout à
fait notre scénographe habituel et qui
dans chaque scène de comptes apporte une
nouvelle innovation une nouvelle touche
et cette fois ci c'est la femme de barbe
bleue qui va apparaître disparaître il
ya des fantômes qui vont parler les
excès les ex femme et sa fille alors oui
oui tout à fait tout à fait alors si ça
reste un décompte qui peut-être feront
le plus peur et encore on a veillé à ce
que la fin soit heureuse et que les
enfants ne sortent pas du tout
traumatisme
bien sûr vous arrivez normand renouvelé
chaque année les thèmes pour noël faire
revenir le public aussi parce que ces
deux buts effectivement alors là
donc c'est vraiment barbe bleue qui va
être la grande nouveauté on renouvelle
aussi avec des comptes différents
racontée par les conteuses donc là les
grossistes spécialement pour noël c'est
effectivement effectivement donc il ya
comme vous le savez toute l'année des
contes de perrault
pendant les vacances de noël la conteuse
va glisser un conte de noël au milieu
des contes de perrault ou même content
de galettes pour la fin des vacances de
noël ce sera plutôt content de galettes
puisqu'on se rapprochera de l'épiphanie
aucune des périodes
ici on parle du château en général il a
toujours toutes ces activités il y a
toujours toutes ces activités la visite
guidée bien sûr c'est quand même
l'élément essentiel de la visite du
château là toutes les pièces du château
toutes les cheminées
tout est décoré hier si sapin répartis
sur le circuit la visite
et puis déboule des guirlandes ça
clignote dans toutes les pièces c'est
assez féerique
voilà pendant tout le mois de décembre
et une bonne partie du mois de janvier
aussi avec toujours une bonne
fréquentation sur cette période là oui
oui oui s'il ya moins qu'il y ait trois
mètres de neige on a beaucoup de monde
ça permet aussi dans les vacances de
noël d'être dans le ton de noël avec il
ya de la neige aussi exactement breteuil
c'est essentiellement une sortie
familiale est effectivement noël est la
période de l'année où les familles sont
réunis il ya les cousins qui sont
ensemble chez les grands parents
donc on a effectivement beaucoup de
monde pendant ces quinze jours de
vacances scolaires on peut retrouver
toutes les éléments pour préparer votre
visite au château sur le site internet
qui va se fait chez opel d'écran
effectivement www.whotels.com là on est
dans l'esprit de noël le moment de noël
il ya d'autres rendez-vous déjà
planifiés pour la suite on en profite
ah oui toute l'année il y aura les
grandes chasses aux oeufs pour pâques
bien sûr on peut déjà noter dans les
agendas
et puis entre les deux il ya moult week
end avec différentes manifestations
tout ça sera visible sur le site on est
en train d plier édité par dans le
dépliant 2019 qui sera diffusée un peu
partout pour les vacances de février il
y aura également les ateliers de sophie
pendant les vacances de février
je crois que 2019 si nenê anniversaire
2019 ce sera le 50e anniversaire de
l'ouverture du château au public en 1969
henri françois et séverine de breteuil
on vers un château en mauvais état deux
pièces au début trois pièces 4 pièces il
a permis de réaliser la meilleure
couverture voilà les premiers
personnages de cire qui sont arrivés
tout ça s'est fait petit à petit mais en
1969 c'était le début d'une grande
aventure
et maintenant 50 ans après le château
est en bon état grâce aux visiteurs qui
sont les mécènes régulier récurrent de
breteuil et profitez en donc pour aller
découvrir ce château pas forcément sous
la neige mais en tout cas dans l'esprit
de noël
[Musique]